[Music]
hi there welcome to chess openings
explained to bridged
i'm nick risco and uh with the help of
dennis sporos uh
prep we're going to be going over the
scandinavian defense today we're going
to be going over the queen a5
line it is one of the oldest lines in
chess one of the earliest recorded
back in the 1400s and it'll be a great
look at
how to develop your pieces in a really
open position so the position starts off
with e4 and d5
this is the scandinavian defense and
black is
willing to trade off a center pawn get
his queen out
get a little bit of queen activity and
play a really solid structure
playing moves like c6 and e6 later in
the position
here white takes on d5
and here black has two options either
the queen can take on d5
or the knight can go to f6 uh
and now the one that's coming up
popularity is the knight f6 line
but the original line is queen takes d5
white plays knight c3 getting a tempo on
the queen
developing a piece and here's the line
we're going to be going over
is queen a5 the other options are queen
d6 and queen d8
with queen d8 being more popular at the
club level and
queen d6 becoming a bit more trendy at
the top level
after queen a5 white decides to take
full center control with d4
put a pawn in the center and try and
build around that
black plays knight f6 developing one of
his minor pieces
and white will continue developing
naturally he plays knight f3
getting his other knight out and here
black plays
c6 kind of the pawn structure that i
mentioned earlier
black is going to be following up with
uh getting his bishop outside the pawn
chain before he plays e6
and then this dark square bishop is
going to be trying to come out
a little bit later we're not exactly
sure where it wants to go yet
here white plays bishop c4 already
prepared to castle king side and black
is going to play
bishop f5 just developing the bishop
getting it outside the pawn chain
and here white plays bishop d2
threatening a couple things here
uh mainly this discovery on the queen
after the knight
goes to let's say d5 or even e4
we have a discovery on the queen
so black will play e6 preparing to
get his dark square bishop uh developed
maybe castle kingside
and he already has a good square for his
knight going to d7 to castle queen side
if he needs to
and here white plays either knight d5
or 94 they both transpose but
the cuter move is knight d5 being
attacked
four times and defended once
but because of this discovery on the
queen the knight is completely safe here
black's only move is queen to d8
this is four says it's the only square
that white does not control
and then here white is going to capture
on f6
now queen takes and pawn takes are both
playable but at the top level you'll see
more
players play g takes the reason is
because after a move like
queen takes f6 there's a white gets
really rapid development can get some
tempo on the queen
now say queen e2 knight d7 and we'll
keep developing naturally
and here black's queen is already
attacked and the engine will give this
as a winning position for white with
plus 1.2
so you'll see a lot of top level players
play pawn takes
and here when we look at the structure
we can notice a couple things
one black is not going to castle king's
side but this damaged pawn structure
is not going to be safe to castle and
put the king on this open
file so black is going to be trying to
castle queen side
in order to do this he's going to have
to develop the queen move the knight and
castle queen side which gives white a
little bit of
time to keep developing his pieces
whites will normally go bishop to b3
he's going to be trying to play queen e2
but he doesn't want to let the c
pawn hang to this bishop on f5
after bishop b3 black is going to
continue with his plan of developing
castle and queen side so knight to d7
queen to e2 and then queen to c7
preparing the castle queen side
both sides castle long and here white
will go
knight h4 i should mention white also
has the option to play knight h4
before castling but it will transpose
into the same line where
after knight h4 bishop g7
both sides will castle and this is the
same position
so bishop goes back to g6 if white ends
up capturing on g6 they have the option
to either take with the h
pawn and open up the file for the rook
or capturing with the f
pawn and then undoubling his pawns
getting a more flexible pawn structure
here the most common move played is g3
kind of getting a pawn chain set up may
play f4
may play h4 after this knight moves he
doesn't want to trade and get the bishop
pair just yet because he will have that
option
at least for the next couple moves
black is going to develop their last
piece with bishop to d6
and now this is where white is going to
capture on g6
and black will capture with the h pawn
opening up the file for his rook without
even
moving his rook at all his rook is well
placed on a semi-open file
here white just plays h4 getting this
pawn chain
set up and now this backwards h pawn
on h2 is not going to be a weakness for
white
as it is protected by a pawn
and here black will play f5 just kind of
playing slowly playing solidly and a way
that white could continue
is king b1 and his chess from here
this is the main line of the queen a5
scandinavian
i just want to give another thanks to
grandmaster dennis boros for helping me
prep this
leave your comments down below if
there's any questions we'll try and
answer them thanks for watching